Hello.
My name is Arun Nagarajan, and
welcome to another exciting
episode of "Google Developers
Live." I'm normally part of
the Apps Group Team, so the
folks that are dialing in
expecting the Drive Team, I'm
making a guest appearance on
behalf of them.
And it's actually a pretty
interesting show today.
So we're going to be talking
about how do you build Google
Drive apps using Apps Script.
Apps Script, those of you who
are not familiar, it's a very
interesting and exciting product
that we have that
allows you to write JavaScript
programs that run on the
Google Cloud that allows you
to automate, extend, and
integrate with Google Apps from
the inside-- so being
able to read your email, being
able to automate calendar
activity, being able to do
things with docs and
spreadsheets, and things
like that.
And Google Drive SDK, on the
other hand, allows you to
build very complex apps that
layer on top of Drive, allow
you to store things in Drive,
be able to open documents in
Drive with your applications.
And in the Google Drive
documentation, you can see a
lot of really good details on
how do you build your apps
using many of the languages that
they have given client
SDKs for and also quick
start guides for.
A lot of these require you
have access to a server,
someplace you can actually
run this code.
The nice thing about Google Apps
Script today that you'll
see is that you'll be able
to build and run these
applications right from the
Google data centers.
So you're able to go to
script.google.com, write your
code, and run it from right
there, and run it as the user
that's accessing it.
So hopefully, at the end of
this, you'll have some sample
code that you walk away with.
We'll put it all on GitHub, as
always, and you'll be able to
kind of get at it and tweak it
and build some interesting
applications.
So a lot of interesting ideas
that we have today.
Let me also show you
a bit about Google
Apps Script, as well.
So Google Apps Script has
a documentation site at
developers.googl
e.com/apps.script, and there's
a lot of really good details
about what can you do.
Just from a quick point to
note is everything under
Default Services is something
that you want to be really
familiar with as far as building
apps with Apps
Script, so even things
like documents.
So this is Google Docs.
So being able to build
a Google doc with
this amount of detail.
So being able to add containers,
alignments
properties, being able
to add footers,
headers, things like that.
So it's really powerful to be
able to access docs and
spreadsheets from within, rather
than the peripheral
things that Google Drive
provides, which is very
powerful integration points.
And of course, the two things
that you can do with the
Google Drive SDK is being able
to do the Create Files.
That's documented here.
Zoom in a little bit, and then
be able to Open Files.
OK.
And we'll build an example
that integrates
with both of that.
Great.
So let's get started.
So the first thing that I'm
going to do is go to
script.google.com.
So that's the one URL you ought
to remember at the end
of this session.
So I get presented with
a nice quick start.
And I'm going to just say that
I'll start from scratch.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to actually copy and
paste some of the code that
I've written ahead of time
just to save us some time.
And I'll explain all the code in
some detail so that you are
able to get a sense for
what this does.
So I'm going to paste this in.
OK.
Save this.
I'll call this My Google Drive
Integration and then
create a new file.
And I'm just segmenting these
into two files for
cleanliness.
It could really be one file.
Call this Apps Script Operations
or something.
Not really the most creative
name, but it
gets the job done.
And in here, I'm going to put in
some code that is specific
to that part of the world.
OK.
Cool.
So before I explain the code,
let me go back and show you
what we're trying to achieve
here in the Google Drive SDK.
So this is My Drive.
So if I go to drive.google.com
as a signed-in user, I get to
see all the files I have.
And you can see that the new
script that I created has
shown up there, as well.
Google's Apps Scripts are
first-class citizens that'll
show up in your drive.
And you're able to see that,
when you hit Create, you get
the sort of rich set of
capabilities that you're able
to do within Google Drive--
create documents, presentations,
and so on.
And you get this little
dialogue that says
Connect more apps.
When you click on that, you
see some really exciting
applications, like being able
to do rich diagramming with
Lucidchart.
I know HelloFax is here.
These are all partners that have
written really exciting
applications for Google Drive
to be able to connect into
your Drive experience.
And our goal is to be able to
surface within this interface
and to be able to do your custom
integration, be able to
run your custom workflows,
and so on.
And this is coming from
the Chrome Web Store.
And in the very first example,
we'll actually directly
install the application without
having to go to the
Chrome Web Store.
OK?
So that's what we're trying to
achieve, is be able to connect
your application to your
Google Drive account.
All right.
So go back in here.
Copy and pasted that code.
And so it's asking to fill
in a few things here.
So the first thing that I need
to do is take this code and
publish it as a web app.
So in order to do that, you
need to Manage Versions.
And then you go under Publish,
Deploy as web app.
And you want to say select the
version you want to run.
And in this case, it's only
one, so it's easy.
And then you want to execute
that as a User
accessing the web app.
And I'm going to say anyone
with a Google account can
access this.
I'll hit Deploy, and
I'll get a URL.
This is the URL that I'll start
to play around with now.
I'll hit copy there.
And I'm going to say that's
my redirect URL.
I'm going to manually
paste that in.
There are ways to
programmatically determine
that, but it's best to manually
paste that in for
debugging and make sure
that you're looking
at the right thing.
The next thing it's asking
me is for client
ID and client secret.
So these are things that
are related to OAuth.
So we'll kind of set that up
really quickly, if I go to
developer.google.com/console.
So OAuth 2 is something that you
have to worry about if you
want to directly allow
installation for the user.
So from here, I'm going
to say Create project.
We'll call this, let's see,
Drive Integration.
OK.
It's creating that.
So in here, I'm going to
turn on Drive SDK.
That's the most important one,
but Drive API, I may need that
in the future, so I'll turn
that on, as well.
And then I'll--
I think it autosaves it.
That's great.
Then I'll come into
API Access.
And here is going to be--
I need to create an OAuth
2.0 client ID.
I'll call this Drive
Integration.
And for now, I'll just use
a dummy for Apps Script
[INAUDIBLE], developers.googl
e.com/apps.scrip
t/images/script-128.png.
And then I'll set that as
the home page, as well.
And then here, I'm going to say
the callback is the URL
that we copied from here.
This guy.
OK.
So this will allow us to manage
the callback workflow
from within our application.
Once I create this, I'll
now have the client
ID and client secret.
So you can see that under
web application.
So I'll delete this project
right after this demo, so this
is something that will
be specific to the
user accessing it.
Then I'll go to client secret,
paste that in.
And then, since I did update
the code, I do have to
redeploy it.
So there is this little
bit of a circular
redeployment that's necessary.
But it's pretty quick overall.
So I'll redeploy it.
Great.
So let's take a look at
what I've done so far.
So I've created a script
within my drive.
This could be directly from
script.google.com, as well.
And over here, I've set up an
OAuth 2.0 workflow that
requests the drive.install
scope.
So this is the critical request
that we're making.
Once this request is fulfilled,
what happens is
this application is connected to
that user's Drive account.
So that's an important
thing to remember.
This drive.install
scope is manually
requested in this case.
If it's coming in from the
Chrome Web Store, it actually
is-- the code becomes
a lot less simpler.
The Chrome Web Store takes
care of that drive, that
install scope for you, and then
gives you access to the
requested scopes from there.
So that's one of things to keep
in mind with the Chrome
Web Store integration.
So in this case, we're manually
requesting install
access instead of them finding
it from the Chrome Web Store.
So I believe I've
republished it.
Great.
So let's take a look at what
happens when I access this.
If I go here, click on this
code, so I'm going
to visit this URL.
So the very first thing it's
going to say, are you giving
this access to these sort of
services that it's asking for?
I have to authorize
that first.
We're working on consolidating
all that scope requirements,
all the authentication flow.
So now, here's the code that
kind of kicks off our
installation process.
Click to start.
And this is the OAuth
2.0 flow.
And it says right here, Add
itself to Google Drive.
You can see that it's asking for
specifically both the Open
With and Create menu.
And I'm going say
Allow access.
OK.
So it's going to install it.
And now I'll be able to go
into it through Drive.
So one of things that I haven't
done yet is be able to
tell it where--
I realize that I haven't
provided
this information here.
I need to go into Google Drive
SDK and then actually register
the callback URL to explicitly
here, as well.
So over here, what I'll just do
is select some images that
I have locally.
Hopefully it'll come up quickly
here on my desktop.
There's one.
I just created a simple image.
Say Select here, as well.
And it should be the
same image for now.
I hit Select.
OK.
And then, I'll say the
URL is that URL that
I had copied before.
And the MIME type I want for
now is application/PDF.
We'll get into this detail
a little bit.
And I'll say Allow people
to create, as well.
And the same URL.
Meeting Notes, I'll say.
And I'll explain that
in a second.
And allow people to import.
So those are the specific
settings for this particular
application that we're
demonstrating.
I hit save changes.
And I'll come back to Drive.
And it should pick up those
changes that I made.
Let me actually manually
reconnect this.
So you can see that under Manage
apps is where I can
sort of disconnect and
reconnect things.
So I'll disconnect that.
Sorry about that confusion.
And I'll revisit that URL.
So it's going to say
Install this App.
It's going to ask me for
permission again.
And I'll say Allow access.
And n it says it's installed.
Or you can navigate to Drive.
So this is very simple HTML that
I've used, and you can
pretty this up.
So now we're back in Drive.
And now, when I click on
this, I should see--
Let's see, I made a mistake
here, I guess.
Let's take a look.
It's not picking up--
Go back to the console.
Save changes-- did it save?
Let's take a look here.
API access, we have that
there under Drive SDK.
Icon.large is filled in,
and application PDF.
Cool.
So let me just make sure
I refresh this.
What did I screw up here?
Let's take a look.
So this is the same account.
So let's take a look at the--
go in here.
So I'll paste that in there.
The token's not correct.
Take a look.
Hmm.
Something's not clicking
correctly there.
I should get a new
option there.
Just double check all my
keys and everything.
So this ends in Bd4.
Go in here.
Go to Publish, Deploy
as web app.
This should also end in Bd4.
Meeting notes is there.
Let's take a look.
What am I missing here?
There should be something.
These are the joys
of live demos.
Hopefully I'll catch the
error quickly here.
Or maybe the order of things
that I did was incorrect.
So let's just quickly
redo this.
Hopefully I'll catch it there.
If I just create a new project,
we'll call this
MyDriveIntegration.
Let's give it a unique name
so I'll catch it.
I'll do this in the correct
order this time around.
Go turn on both Drive
API and Drive SDK.
It takes a second there.
So those are saved.
I can now see Drive
SDK is enabled.
I'll select the icons again.
Pick that guy.
I see a little collage there.
Go ahead and pick this.
OK.
So the URL will use the same
URL, application/PDF.
Create with.
Save that.
Meeting Notes.
OK.
So let's see if I
got everything
correctly this time.
I don't want to initiate
the flow directly.
And I say Save changes.
And if I go to API Access,
create a new token.
Call it apps script.
Update.
Script.
Images.
Update.
And I'll just say for now,
developers.googl
e.com/apps-script.
Next.
and I'll say More options.
Paste that in for
the callback.
We don't want that.
Create that.
And I'll create this
client ID.
Go back in here.
Client ID.
Paste that in.
And then Client secret.
OK.
File, Manage versions.
Save a new version.
Publish.
User accessing the
web app update.
OK.
Click on that.
So that should now force
me to reinstall again.
And let's see if we're
lucky this time.
If not, I have a backup.
Oh, there it is.
It just took a couple of extra
seconds, it seemed.
I have it installed twice.
I apologize for the
confusion there.
So let's take a look at
what we're trying
to accomplish here.
So we got a couple of icons.
I'll just leave it be for now.
Maybe there was just
a refresh issue.
So I'll go back and kind
of showcase what I'm
trying to do here.
So in my calendar, I have a
currently ongoing meeting
called Status meeting.
So this is a meeting that
I have, and I've
invited a few people.
And I have a set of agenda
items in here that we're
trying to walk through.
This is completely fictitious.
And I like to, when I have
a meeting, have an agenda
written out ahead of time, and
then have a Meeting notes
document that goes along with
it, where I can track action
items, and check off things that
we accomplish against the
agenda, and so forth.
So what I would like, in my
Drive, is to be able to say,
when I say Create Meeting
Notes, have it scan my
calendar using the Apps Script
API, which is extremely
succinct and able to run very
quickly using the JavaScript
APIs that we have.
And then create a document
with the notes from that
pre-populated, and then also
potentially share it out with
other folks, and so on.
So if I can say Create Meeting
Notes, you can see that it's
spinning away.
And it called back
into our code.
You can see that
script.google.com is the callback.
And now, when I hit "click here
to open," there's the
document that got
created for me.
So you can see that Meeting
notes for Status meetings,
which is sort of the subject
that it took from the calendar
appointment itself, and then
it nicely formatted
something for us.
So let's take a look
at this code.
So here's the code
that gets run.
Very simple function here that
says find the two-hour window.
Pretty naive set of logic that
I'm using, but this is just an
example to demonstrate
what's possible.
And then it does
DocumentApp.create So this is
the line of code that creates
the Google document, and then
appends some content into it--
a few paragraphs, the horizontal
rule, and then
another paragraph.
And then it gets the URL from
which we can very quickly
click in and open.
So you can see that a very
few lines of code--
I think it's about 25 lines of
code, including the code to
get the email list of
people that are
in the meeting itself.
And you can see that
it's pretty
straightforward to do this.
So you can see that this is
getting called from this sort
of end point, which is, as you
know from the Google Drive
SDK, the Apps Script code gets a
callback with the parameters
that the user requested.
So in this case, specifically
the user
requested the create action.
And when create is done, I don't
care for any other sort
of details.
I'll just say
createMeetingNotes, which will
scan the calendar and then get
the URL back, and we'll
display the URL right there.
Pretty straightforward, and you
can see that it's actually
kind of amazing how
short this can be.
And I can show you the
code looks like--
it looks for this JSON object.
So when you say Create, there
is a parameter called state,
right there, which gets sent it
in the get parameter, and
it contains these sort of
attributes within it, and same
for open files.
OK.
And we'll do that,
as well, next.
So, so far, we've done one
simple demo, which is takes my
calendar data and then
automatically creates a Google
document for me as the
account that I'm
currently logged in at.
And that's happening because
when we published it, if you
recall, we set it as Execute
the app as a user accessing
the web app, not as the person
authored the code, but the
person accessing it.
So you can see that just by
authorizing the user against
the script.
it listed all the things--
Calendar, Gmail, documents,
and so on.
By listing that, the
authorization is taken care of
in one shot, and you're able to
write code against all the
different APIs that
we have access to.
Let's take a look at what else
that we can do here.
So one of the things that is
problematic sometimes is to be
able to send a lot of documents
at once from Google
Drive to a person that may not
be using Google docs or
spreadsheets, and so on.
So maybe they wanted a PDF, or
some other printer-friendly or
more standard format that can
be viewed from anywhere
without a Google account.
So one of the things that I
imagine would be interesting
for this example is what if
there was an extension that we
could write.
When you run it, it's able to
take the file you've selected,
convert it to a PDF, zip it up,
and then be able to send
an email to yourself or someone
else that you want to
share it with?
This is great when we're working
with folks that are
not with the Google Docs or that
you want to send it as an
attachment that can be viewed by
anyone without an account.
So it's a great example of how
you can do multiple steps
within the same exact script.
So here's one where the same
option's available when you do
right-click, Open with.
Or if I select multiple options
here, I can do it from
right-click here, as well.
And you can see that the
right-click option's available
if I say More, Open with.
You know what I didn't do?
In my console, I didn't
enable multiple--
there should be an option here
for Multiple File Support.
So I didn't select that.
If I had selected that, it'll
allow me to do that for
multiple options.
But for now, we'll just do it
in one example, and I think
that'll satisfy the demo here.
If I right-click here,
and I say Open with--
this is not the window,
this is the window.
If I right-click here, and say
Open with and say send to Open
with, Drive Integration, what
that's going to do is it's
going to open up our app.
You can see that it's spinning
with our example there.
And it's going to take that and
send it to it as an inbox.
You can see, if I come back to
my Inbox, there should be an
email here waiting.
You know what?
I picked the one that I
uninstalled, I believe.
So we'll go here, and I'll say
Open with, apps script.
This guy.
So by registering two versions,
I think I've screwed
up parts of this.
There it is.
Files you requested.
And there's a zip file.
And I can download it.
And I can open that up.
And there should be a--
let's see, where are
we in my Finder?
Lot of files in there.
And it should say
files for you.
Then this is my status
meeting example
that I had used, right?
So that's a PDF file.
So you see how easy it is.
And we'll take a look at
the code, as well.
And this code is actually even
more straightforward.
This says, if I am going into
the one with multiple files,
it's going to go in here, and
say, let's take a look at this
code, which is zipAndSend.
And that's going to take all
the different IDs, get the
email address of the person
that's currently logged in.
And it's going to iterate
through all the different
files, get a version of it with
the PDF attached to it as
a file name, and then it's going
to turn them into one
file called FilesForYou.zip
and then mail it to you.
So you can see that it's
extremely straightforward to
build these sort of workflows
without having to
write a lot of code.
So one of the nice things is
that you can actually submit
this to the Chrome Web Store.
So we have ability-- and let
me zoom out a little bit,
because I think it's
hard to see all the
aspects of the editor.
One of things you can actually
do is you're able to say
Publish and then Register
in Chrome Web Store.
So what this does is, it
essentially whitelists the URL
for this particular script
deployed as a web app in the
Chrome Web Store registry.
So that means you own the URL,
and you're going to be able to
register that as a Drive app
or whichever type of
application you want
to deploy it as.
So by doing this--
let's just walk through this.
So I'll say Register
as web app.
So you can see that it says,
"Communicating with Chrome Web
Store." Just take a
couple seconds.
And it comes back
with a success.
And what it does is creates
the project in draft mode.
So you will not publish the app
as is, because it's not
set to the right
container type.
So if I go to the Chrome
Developer dashboard--
and there is a one-time fee of
$5 to access your account, to
verify your account.
If I go back to your Developer
dashboard, you can see that
there's a listing here created
for you called My Google Drive
Integration.
So you will, however, not
publish this version.
What you'll do is you'll create
a manual manifest.
And let me actually go back to
this guy here and zoom in a
little bit.
Let's see, I don't know
how to zoom in in
this particular editor.
So let me just kind of zoom
in with this guy.
So you can see that in
this particular--
here's a sample manifest file.
The operative--
there are two important
things about this.
The container needs to be
set to GOOGLE_DRIVE.
And this, of course,
is all documented.
And the api_console_project_id
needs to match the API project
console from here, this guy,
this API ID, the app ID.
And you can see the same
thing listed under
Overview, as well.
So that's the project number
that you'll want to make sure
that is available in
that manifest.
So that's how we tie back which
project that you're
doing, which API project
this is correlated to.
The last thing is to ensure that
your launch URL matches
the deployed web app
that you have, OK?
So that's actually an important
step to ensure that
you've got the right things.
Once you're able to do that,
if you go back to the
Developer Dashboard here,
and go to Add new item--
and the important thing here is
to make sure that you read
through these important
descriptions about the icon
file, the description.
It's actually much more a
restricted set of sizes you
can upload.
It ensures that you have the
right amount of details in
your description, so definitely
walk through these
steps here to understand
exactly
what you need to upload.
And I think the documentation
is great here to get a sense
for what you can do.
And just to complete the set
of demos, I actually had
published previously as a very
simple application that
enables you to do what I did
with the select multiple files
and send it as an email.
So I'll go back to My Drive
and showcase that example.
If I go to Create, go to
connect more apps.
So this is already submitted,
already available for anyone
to check out.
It's called File Assistant.
And you can see that there's
a little icon.
I've re-used the same
icon from there.
And you can see the URL is a
script.google.com account, a URL.
So I hit Connect.
And I'm going to say don't
make a default for now.
I hit OK.
So you can see that there's no
OAuth flow here that I had to
deal with at this point.
I can just say More, Open
with, File Assistant.
So in this particular example, I
had correctly selected allow
multiple files, and I
hit File Assistant.
This is going to go through
the process of kicking off
that script.
And email sent.
So you can see that in that
particular example of an app
that was already submitted to
the web store, there was not
even OAuth 2 drive.install scope
request that you had to
walk through.
So here's an example where, if
I open this up, there are
multiple files in there that
I had previously selected.
So that's a very quick example
of the benefits of being able
to install it from
Chrome Web Store.
But hopefully you saw that you
can actually deploy this
within your domain or
restrictive set of users by
just requesting the OAuth
2 drive.install scope.
So that, I think, is about
the set of things
that I wanted to show.
What I'll definitely make sure
is that all the code that we
had demonstrated here
will be available
for you to play with.
And we'll start to think about
new ways to demonstrate the
Apps Script and Google Drive
Integration in future episodes.
One of the things I did want to
mention is a lot of folks
ask us about when do you use
Google Drive SDK and when do
you use the Apps Script API.
And they're actually
very complementary.
The Google Drive API is probably
more similar in some
cases, but that provides a
more RESTful interface.
The Google Apps Scripts
programs, the apps, they run
on the Google data centers
themselves.
And it's pure JavaScript.
It's cloud based, and you're
able to, like I said, write
your code, author it, be able
to publish it all from a
browser without having to open
up an IDE, like Eclipse, or
install SDKs to manage that.
So the Drive SDK allows you to
run this and integrate your
applications deep within
the Drive UI.
The Apps Script API can run
under the user's context on
the server side.
So hopefully all that
made sense.
Looking forward to seeing what
kind of applications you guys
build and hearing more
feedback from you.
Thank you very much.